somebody basically posted a job opening
at Fox which turned out to be absolutely
Sac religious so I put out what I
thought was sort of a Kumbaya post
saying hey let's stay away from politics
I'm sure what got very well Catherine
everybody sort of went ah yes Kumbaya so
people called me a white supremacist a
Nazi adjacent you know I I just I
collaborate with the Nazis and the KK
Clan it just got so extreme how do we
fix this
Catherine Katherine Brodsky tell us your
cancellation story to question we ask
all our guests at this point his every
guest has been canceled that's the
qualification okay well my cancel story
which is now about two years ago and you
know are you checking your watch to make
sure it's been two years okay um that
sorry you know it's something that um
it's funny kind of to talk about it now
in some ways because at the time it was
so intense what was going on for me
because I've never encountered that sort
of thing before in a personal way so
what happened was I um I used to uh well
I still kind of do I had a group for
women um journalists and it was a job
board and it was a job group on Facebook
and what we did was basically you know
um it was a spin-off of another group
that was called kind of binders for
women uh it was a joke sort of off of
that reference to Mid Romney's exactly
binders full of women exactly although
some there's some debate as whether it
was or wasn't now but um anyways I I
decided Well what does everyone want job
so I started this group agreed to being
about 30,000 U
members um and in it it was just people
posting jobs we didn't have any like
personal discussions nothing like that
just jobs
and one day um somebody basically posted
a job opening at Fox which turned out to
be you know absolutely sacrilegious and
even the way she posted it was sort of
apologetic we're trying to diversify The
Newsroom we're changing things but
people just went and attacked this PO
woman and I thought you know that's that
was not right so I put out what I
thought was sort of a Kumba post saying
hey um let's stay away from politics uh
we've had so much coming apart let's
come
together I did not expect what sort of
I'm sure it worked out very well
Catherine everybody sort of went ah yes
Kumbaya when I tell this story everybody
knows what's going to happen next but I
really truly did not see it coming I
really didn't so people called me a
white supremacist a Nazi adjacent you
know I just i' collaborate with the
Nazis and the KK Clan it just got so
extreme and after that I was I was also
somebody who's always had believed in
freedom of speech I mean I still do but
I did learn a lot from that because
there is a difference between engaging
with all speech and a difference between
engaging bad fave good fave speech so at
a certain point I realized okay this is
not this is not very helpful and there
were like
66 no 6 66 comments at the time where I
sort of decided okay that's enough and
everybody was attacking me and they said
that inherently you can't take politics
out of a group that's for
women um because by Nature that makes it
political and I said okay I did think
about this for a little while and I said
well I'll make it open to everyone I'll
give a month's notice uh you can remove
your content if you want if you want to
start your own group you can do that so
um but that actually went even worse and
that's when I started getting docked I
had people emailing editors saying you
know so that they would never hire me
again since I'm a journalist and uh also
people sending me like I I would get
images of people Mobs with Tor TIY
torches just vile kind of messages all
around people with attack me uh you know
and if I'd be on a panel or something it
would suddenly come up and people would
sort of harass
me and now I kind of feel about it you
know sort of okay about it not okay but
um I I think I've gone through that
process and I've come on the other side
but at the time as somebody who is
actually pretty much kind of a people
pleaser in many ways I'm not un like I
think we talked about this at some point
uh you you're much more I'm in the top
one one percentile for disagreeable yeah
you're disagreeable I can be
disagreeable on things that I have very
strong feelings about that are strong
convictions but I'm not generally trying
to be disagreeable with people so it was
it was just a very sort of at the time
now I can use the word traumatic because
I remember for a while I talked to
people and I felt like I had to give
them I wonder what they knew about me
what they Googled what they thought and
um it's uh it's been kind kind of a a
long journey and as a result of all of
this happening though I because I was
already sort of struggling with my own
sort of free speech and and being able
to articulate what I was thinking on in
my head and I little by little started
you know doing that more and I think
that opened the Watershed for it and I
got to know a lot of interesting people
and uh that's where I'm now Katherine
what do you think it says about our
society that a post as innocuous as
yours that was designed to be in your
words kumay can open the door to all
this vital well I think there is I think
there's a few things going on because I
think now that I look at it a lot of it
was really mobs and bullying that's at
the essence that's what it is it's it's
a mob and it's big enough that they're
all sort of bullying people and when and
they all sort of with each other and
therefore they confirm and reaffirm
every thought that they have so they're
not really able to think outside of the
mob and it's that very human instinct
that people have had throughout history
um but that's what I was seeing because
people talk about you know cancel
culture and they say well it's
accountability culture and you know what
I agree sometimes it is sometimes there
there do need to be repercussions for
certain things the problem that I have
with it is that a post that is I do
think is quite innocent um was intended
to sort of do the right thing gets this
disproportionate reaction where there is
no conversation there's no way out and
and the punishment that's being doled
out is kind of the same no matter what
the crime is if there even was a crime
and there obviously was no crime you
were allowed to watch Fox News you're
allowed to work for fo Fox News but not
in the eyes of a certain segment of
society who you seem to royally piss off
right and the thing is I it's not like
I'm a a big Fox News supporter myself I
don't watch the Fox News I I don't like
a lot of it but um but if somebody wants
to work for an organization like why am
I in the shoes of deciding who should
apply for job where like if you go to
LinkedIn the at l in LinkedIn you know
you can post a job at any organization
and nobody really has an issue with it
as long as they're within the bounds of
the law and for me you know when I you
know when I was being attacked it's hard
not to think okay maybe people have a
point because so many people are going
against you so aggressively and in my
case again because I am somebody who's
kind of a people pleaser in some ways um
you know I didn't want people to be mad
at me and so I did think a lot about you
know where they might have a point where
they might not and where I realized I
drew the line is I I asked myself the
question if I were in their shoes and I
disagreed with myself very strongly how
would I
behave and one thing I would never do is
try to ruin somebody's career write them
atrocious messages uh you know send tiki
torches call them names all those kinds
of things were not ways I'd engage so
even if they had some sort of a point
you don't I realized for myself if you
don't engage with those kinds of people
if somebody sent me you know thoughtful
messages that were not trying to you
know destroy my life and were in good
faith I'm fine I will I will absolutely
listen to that I think it's important to
but in that case that's not what was
happening and that completely changed my
thinking on it and actually what I ended
up doing is I also wrote my first opad
at the time it was for Newsweek and it
was about this particular thing that
happened to me and at the time people
thought that if I publish that I would
be completely destroyed and I thought
that too I didn't know for sure right
and um but I thought if I couldn't speak
out on this issue that I'm saying that
wasn't affecting just me because in all
of this people were sending me messages
of saying you know I see what's
happening to you it's not right and I
feel so ashamed because I too afraid to
speak out I was getting a lot of those
messages and then on top of it I was
getting messages saying you know you um
this has happened to me and this is my
story and you know some people have lost
their livelihood completely some people
just can't do anything so you know it
wasn't just my story uniquely this was
happening all around I just happened to
walk into it myself as well but because
I did I was suddenly really exposed to
all the people have gone through this
and when I wrote the story you know
which I think it was called the rise of
the righteous bullies or something like
that and I that is something that I
completely um while I was scared I felt
like I had to do it and when it came out
I actually had a lot more
support and the people who were bullying
me
stopped and I think that was sort of
because if they continued to do that
directly to me well that would just
reinforce what I just said about them
well bullies always pick on people
people who don't fight back that's how
they operate I'm curious to tease out
the point you made about accountability
culture because you said that there are
situations where you you kind of agree
with it what kind of situations are you
talking about well if somebody um has
committed a certain crime that hurt
people um if someone I think you really
have to judge it on such a situational
basis and I think that's what's not
happening we are taking like anybody
does anything a little bit wrong and
it's treated equally wrong um so there
are certainly people who might have you
know let's say they abused their uh
employees um I think or they said some
you know really atrocious things that I
don't want to say it on here but there's
certainly some things that I think would
qualify to having some sort of R
percussion even if that repercussion is
like oh I won't work with you right I
think you're kind of an abhorent human
being maybe you're appraising terrorists
or something like that um but and and
that is up to each individual to decide
because we do have freedom of
Association as well and I think that's
important to remember nobody's forced
should be forced to spend time with
people they don't like um but I do like
to encourage people to spend PE time
with people they might have some
disagreements with well there's a
difference between those two things and
I think the point you're talking about
I've made this point a lot which is
that like what happened to Harvey
Weinstein I'm I fully support that me
too what happened to aiz andari was an
Abomination and that's that's the issue
is that we tie everybody with the same
brush and there's no difference in
people's heads between someone who's
actually like a rapist or a terrorist or
whatever yeah and somebody who just
happens to be on a similar you know the
same concept is involved but like sex is
involved let's say but nothing else is
similar but yet people treated get
treated very very similarly well I know
a writer I've been talking to recently
he got in trouble and lost his job
because you know the comparison that he
made between Hitler and Stalin in terms
of impact on lives and you know I
actually didn't necessarily agree with
the way he framed it but he doesn't
deserve to be cancelled for it for for
something he's just thinking through and
maybe said stated it not in the most uh
proper way I suppose so you hear stories
like that all the time and obviously
I've been exposed to hearing a lot of
people's stories and that's the problem
that I have it's not that there is some
sort of an accountability culture is
that there is this disproportionate way
of punishing people and weaponizing it
and that it is applied sometimes to
people who don't deserve it at all like
quite often actually but also to to
people who um you know might have
committed a small little sin you know
and and don't need to be punished in a
way that takes away their destroys their
whole life and I think a lot of the
times it comes out of this sort of
psychological gleeful bully mentality
and people gang up some of the people
that I've talked
to um when uh one of the people that I
talked to when researching for a book
that I wrote uh he was saying how when
when when he got cancelled some of the
people who were fiercely attacking him
didn't even remember it later on so can
you imagine like what is the psychology
of that where someone was participating
in a mob essentially it's an online mob
but it's a mob and doesn't
remember
so that happens a lot too and I think a
lot of times people are not thinking
through what that's such a good point K
I guess what you what you've got your
finger on there is
online communication makes bullying much
easier MH so if you were to go and
physically bully people you You'
struggle to not remember that but online
it's like oh yeah done yeah and then you
move on to you know what's in the news
what's for breakfast Etc it makes it
easy and therefore you can see why these
dynamics that have always existed in
human society as you say become more
prominent because it's like well it's
right there you know take your phone out
somebody go to work you know well it's
easy and it's also you don't have to
face somebody right and I think that's a
colossal difference I I you know even I
speak about pretty contentious things
with people in real life all the time
people with all sorts of perspectives on
these things people who strongly
disagree sometimes and I've never had
any incidents that were like this or
even really having bad experience
exchange you know because you see each
other's reactions you're face to face
you understand that this person is maybe
thinking something through exploring or
um you know comes in good faith and has
has their heart in the right place but
you don't see that online because it
takes out your whole humanity and and
and makes you a cartoon character to
people so even when they attack you they
don't really see you as a human being
they see you as some sort of a
descriptor of they've decided to kind of
imprint on you and it's also that the
difference in perspective which constant
in touched on but I think sometimes
people aren't even
aware do you see what you're not even
aware of what you're doing because it's
you're so disengaged from the process
like you could even be just making a
joke about it but it appears to the
person who's at the receiving end if you
are on the receiving end of literally 6
million jokes or whatever is you're like
this is awful that is a good point I've
um I've been told not to read comments
on appearances I do and I am bad at
listening so I've read a lot and
sometimes they're so so terrible and but
in particular if it was just
one you shrug it off but then when
there's so many use quantity has a
quality all of its own as Jose of sty
and F saides it's true it it kind of
does yeah we'll be back with our guest
in a minute but first let me tell you
about these Super Beat heart chws we've
been using here at trigonometry Towers
if you're looking for a way to turn your
snacking habit into an easy way to
support your health without sacrificing
flavor then heart tubes may be the
perfect solution paired with a healthy
lifestyle the antioxidants and super
beats are clinically shown to be nearly
two times more effective at promoting
normal blood pressure than a health
healthy lifestyle alone for me the best
thing about super beats heart chews is
that they're a great way to limit my
caffeine intake I really love the chews
have replaced my midm morning coffee
because the chewes support healthy
circulation you not only get blood
pressure support but you also get heart
healthy energy which comes importantly
without the crash the chws are
incredibly convenient no pills to
swallow no ingredients to mix or prepare
they're very easy to add to your routine
double your potential with super beats
heart chws get a free 30-day supply of
super beat heart chws and 15% off your
first order by going to getup beats.com
and using promo code trig that's get
super
be ts.com code trig now back to the
interview and what I'm interested in
particular is how this culture has
affected Ed the media because you've
been a journalist for a long long time
and a writer so how have you seen this
affect journalism in the media from when
you started to now yeah I mean the
biggest changes I would say there is
this a lot of young people go into
journalism with the state of mind that
they want to be activists the people
that I worked with who are you know old
school they don't have I mean the same
mindset I mean all of us want to make a
difference in the world we we choose
which Stories We report on because might
be more interested in them or maybe want
to bring attention to certain issues but
um there was a Structure um that that
promoted a different quality of
Journalism and now it's like it is
opinion journalism in many many
Publications but the other thing I see I
see a lot of friction between the old
generation New Generation you can I know
specific cases and in some of the big
kind of mainstream newsrooms too where
they are fighting it out um and you know
the fight the people who fight to be
activists are more vicious
so so people lose their jobs or become
very um it becomes very difficult for
them to speak and you know the there's a
lot of opinions in the world you know
and and people on the left have a lot of
opinions like there's a tremendous
diversity of opinions on different
issues that we're grappling with and I
worked in journalism and I worked in
film and I know that there's people who
have who are very sort of high level
very successful who have very strong
opinions about things including stronger
opinions than I do and they're so afraid
to say anything that is the key and when
you're afraid to say anything then we
don't have a world that makes sense
because we don't we don't have the back
and forth that we really really need to
make sure that we understand the
different perspectives that we
understand what's actually going on when
people are afraid to speak that's the
big issue for me and people get more
radicalized whether it's the left or the
right because they're now only talking
to people in their little orbit and so
and those people are just confirming
their views so it causes the centers to
sort of collapse because I do believe a
lot of people um have pretty reasonable
points of views but they're the people
who are quiet and the people who are
loudest are the people with radical
thoughts and so that's all we end up
hearing and then the world becomes
shaped by these radical thinkers and I
would say as well there is another
radicalization uh Vector that's going on
as well and we've seen it we're
recording this a couple of weeks after
the Hamas attack on Israel and you see
in the West for example uh the
conversation about illegal immigration
and mass immigration in general has been
very uh it's been very curtailed by the
fact that certain opinions which are
quite widely shared in society about
restricting immigration about
restricting immigration particularly
from certain parts of the world uh where
there you know you are bringing people
in where there's a much higher risk of
them being a danger to to the society
into which they're coming all of that
was kept under a lid and then suddenly
people see in the streets of Western
capitals massive uh this is even before
Israel responded massive effectively Pro
terrorism rallies right and people are
like whoa how did this happen and and
now they're being radicalized by that
experience as I think everybody is
actually in some extent to some extent
certainly in ourspace because the
consequences of not being able to talk
about those things for two decades and
now showing up in your streets and now
people probably are going to overreact
uh I certainly think that is one of the
possible outcomes of this no absolutely
I I think so too and I would say that um
I mean that happens a lot the
overreaction right a lot of the the sort
of counter movements that are not so
great do happen I don't blame normal
people for overreacting in the situation
because they're finally aware of the
scale of the problem yeah you see what
I'm saying yeah I do but I think that
when it comes to immigration and
particular and both you and I are
immigrants to probably have some some
understanding and some sympathy um I
think the problem is because there's a
difference talking about something and
being politically correct versus you
know being a a complete jerk about it
and having you know maybe bigoted racist
views those are not the same things you
want to be able to be honest about the
facts of anything and you have to also
understand the different perspectives
like you know you take a country like
Japan for example which people rarely
criticize for their immigration policies
um but people love Japan why do they
love Japan they love it because the
cultur it's Japanese yeah it's Japanese
exactly and Japan has an deeply
restrictive immigration policy and but
but it's sort of necessary for the
culture not to be
destroyed and you know if we're talking
about countries like America America or
Canada where they're all immigrants
essentially it's a little bit different
and I think you have to look at
different countries in different
contexts and and the context of how most
people want to live there as well um but
that's not happening it's like the same
lens is applied everywhere and you can't
be honest about the things that aren't
working um because if we can talk about
the things that aren't working maybe we
can and we can all talk about it
together by the way that's how we can
come up with Solutions to these problems
and maybe those Solutions are not going
to be so extreme or maybe you know not
discriminatory because you'll have a
balance of points of views but people
are afraid to talk to each other who
disagree or Not Afraid but they don't
want to is that sorry Francis I know you
want to jump in and you should but I
just want to finish on this point is
that what's happening is it the people
are afraid to talk to each other because
I would argue Al I mean what I yes I
personally would argue I'm not even
playing Devil's Advocate that it's not
that people are afraid to talk to each
other it's that the expression of
concerns from people of a particular
view on one side of the political
Spectrum has been consistently demonized
so those phrases you used about bigoted
racist Etc they have been badly
misapplied in order to maintain the lies
that people on the left want to maintain
in the public space yeah um I I
understand what you're saying I think
there is a a re action that is coming
from the right that is a direct response
to the left you know calling them
racists and not listening to them and
demonizing them at the same time I think
it's about who has the power at any
given moment so if the right now the
left clearly has more at least
institutional power when the right has
more institutional power they'll do the
same thing the reactions I think are I
understand them um but they're not
really healthy and helpful so you have
people who really vilify each other from
both sides and one is I think the right
is feeling sort of
victimized and victims lash out and we
saw that again the left did the same
when they didn't have power they also
lashed out and interestingly enough they
were much more per Free Speech you know
I grew up with that being a very
inherent quality right like a very
important value and now because the left
has that power suddenly well we want to
control it this speech is okay but not
this speech and I cons constantly meet
people um and they say yeah no I totally
support Free Speech but you know there
should be
limits well outside of that limit of you
know let's not Insight
violence then you don't actually believe
in free speech you believe in limited
speech um but I think think what I'm
seeing on the right unfortunately
because when I first you know started
this journey my allies were often people
on the right because they you know were
proponents of free speech they didn't
like what was going on with the
culture But as time kind of went on I
feel like people have gotten much more
radicalized including the people who are
sort of fighting this anti-woke or
rather the wokeness right um so the
anti-woke Warriors as I would call them
um because they start employing the same
techniques as the people they've
criticized and that's something that I'm
seeing in the culture that's been
disturbing me the other thing that's
been disturbing me actually is seeing
the media reflect these practices so you
read a media a media article a newspaper
article from a publication you thought
was once reputable and you're and you're
going am I just reading someone's
Facebook post here is that what this is
you probably are I mean you know there's
only so much time in the day you have to
make do so you have to post it
everywhere yeah I I mean there's so many
articles where I would catch them and
they would say you know it would say
news but it's clearly in every objective
metric it's an opinion piece and this is
the problem like as a writer you know
that certain Publications are captured
and it will never if if in fact if I
pitch certain stories to them they're
going to you know put me on a black list
but in you know in their head
I don't think there is not yet there is
not Blacklist but at the same time
because because I've been so much more
vocal with my criticism and with my
voice a lot of people reach out to me
often very discreetly and privately and
they all they see the issues and some of
them are at very top positions too at
some of these Publications which I find
sort of baffling because while I believe
like anybody everybody should be to make
their own decisions how they want to you
know tackle this or not um it's it's the
silence it's the deafening silence that
is actually allowing for a lot of this
to thrive because if these people like
push back right away and they have a lot
of power like it they're not all you
know people at the bottom who who don't
have any power or control but they're
all they really are scared and that's
depressing because if you look at the
media from 20 30 years ago you or 40
years ago there's you can name so many
journalists who were fire Brands who
were out there who said outrageous
things but were interesting and had a
unique perspective is that all gone well
and and I think it's really important to
highlight the importance of being wrong
and allowing people to be wrong because
if if you're never wrong you never get
corrected um I and if and you continue
thinking that wrong thing in your head
too so I think there is this kind of
Puritan culture almost where you have to
adhere to these very specific things you
can never say anything a little bit off
a little bit wrong but you know if
you're hanging out with your friends and
you know a friend made a joke and it's
like dude that's a little bit much it's
a little over the line right okay you
say that you move on and a it gives them
feedback and B
you understand that your friend is a
good person that may have accidentally
uttered something that maybe wasn't
quite appropriate we don't destroy the
friendship over this we don't D go and
destroy that person over this but
somehow it's become okay to destroy
people just because they misspoke people
who are strangers because you don't
understand what the the whole context of
it is who they are what they really mean
what they're thinking I'm sure all say
inappropriate things at times sometimes
it's a purely an accident it's it's not
malicious a lot of the time but you're
being held to this standard I had
somebody go after me for um
mispronouncing her name really yeah and
that that was a
microaggression so and and and caused it
to you know that ended up being a whole
campaign against me because suddenly I'm
a racist person because I mispronounced
me name and you know that another day I
mispronounced a person from my own
background's name nine times repeatedly
because I'm not very good at pronouncing
certain
words and the thing that I want to touch
on is that you talked about destroying
friendships we are now destroying
friendships we're destroying
relationships we're
destroying working relationships and the
thing that's really sad is we have a
loneliness crisis people are talking
about being more lonely than ever me men
in particular are lonelier than ever
there's a horrifying stat I can't
remember exactly what the percentage is
of men who have got no friends zero
friends these are the things that keep
you going when times are tough and we're
just throwing it on the metaphorical
fire because people say things that we
disagree with and to me that seems
tragic yeah and I think a lot of it is
also social media um because um I did I
did a survey for example um amongst my
um followers but also Elon Musk
Amplified it so I got quite a few
responses and I thought it was
interesting because I had a hunch
already about this but I asked how many
people are have been in are currently in
a relationships or have been dating you
know in the last year and then the
second category was you know people
who've been dating between you know
somebody have dated somebody within the
last year or two and then the last
category was you know two plus years it
was about I think it was like
45% something like that haven't gone on
a single date in over two years so
you've got a massive Insel audience
that's what you're
saying I don't even think it's my
audience but but I it's something no I
understand but it's something that in a
lot of U uh because a lot of discussions
that I've sort of said and it was quite
a surprising thing because you're saying
it's a this pandemic of loneliness is
very true a lot of times people write to
me about their loneliness and they want
someone to talk to and and it's very you
know I think we don't really have
communities in the same way anymore and
I think that's a major contributing
factor to this um but also you know Co
didn't help matters right dating apps
people aren't used to meeting each other
in in just in real life and hey let's
let's go out I don't know how you do it
I've never picked anybody up so but but
it's like that isn't happening and then
on top of it you know you'd have these
communities um you know and they' get
and you think you belong whether it's
women writers or there's some a lot of
controversy for some reason in the
knitting circles which you would
think but but you you become part of a
group and that becomes your identity and
then your identity is completely
shattered when the group turns on you
because you somehow straight from the
Orthodoxy and that's a thing that people
are really scared of really scared of
and understandably so cuz we're
programmed to want to be in the group so
I guess can you really blame people for
not wanting to speak up yes
yes man up you cowards that's right look
I I had I had a bit of a different
perspective starting out with this and
it's has shifted I was a lot more
forgiving of people not speaking up um
because you know I understood their
fears I felt it myself so I get where
they're coming
from but I think there's a point at
which you are contributing to this and
also if you cannot stand up for your
friend for example or if you can't stand
up for something that is
absolutely the right thing to
do that
isn't that's how it's very difficult to
live with yourself that's why people
expressed feelings of Shame and I did I
reassured them at the time I said please
don't feel this way it's you know your
support even like this means a lot and
it did it was
sincere but it is contributing that is
how we got here I think people really do
need to find their voices and speak up
especially you don't have to do it for
everything you know there's things where
it doesn't matter or you know it doesn't
matter enough to you but the things that
really matter that you believe really
matter you need to find the courage to
do that and um and a lot of the people
that I've talked to who have sort of
Found the courage it's not even courage
it's just the sense of I can't do it any
other way I can't live with myself if I
don't stand up for a friend or I don't
stand up for this against this thing
that is wrong and how somebody's being
treated if somebody's being prosecuted
and you see it and you see it in so many
areas too so you know people are so
afraid to dissent well whether it's art
or it's science in a lot of scientific
communities that has become very
controversial but Science is based to
some extent on dissenting and if there
is there's a false sense of consensus
when sometimes there isn't consensus on
particular things you know the whole
science is settled aspect it's not
always settled but people are under the
impression that it is because other
people are afraid um of what is going to
happen to them at the same time you do
have to recognize like you hear all
these stories of people who stood up and
and they are so successful now and
they're
famous uh they's so so so so many
stories that are not told of people
who've lost everything who' lost their
jobs or not successful that happens a
lot more often and you know when you
make a choice that's why I can't just
say hey you have to do this because that
person does have to make that choice for
themselves because they could lose
everything well right and I was joking
when I was like my man up ow to some
extent because you're right it's not
something that's easy for everybody
there is an argument to be had about
whether you know speaking up for
something that really matters like a
friend being destroyed and paying the
price for it is a bad thing to do I mean
sometimes it's okay to pay a price for
doing the right thing if that weren't
the case it would be easier and
everybody would do it right um but I'm
curious because it is a lot to ask of
people uh whether we can spend a few
minutes talking about how you think some
of this gets addressed because in your
upcoming book you talk about this um how
do we fix this Katherine yeah I mean
that's a really great question and and I
find that it doesn't get asked very much
I think we we have a lot of grievances
but we don't yeah both sides and
everybody who's not on the side like us
is very tempted to talk about victimhood
and we don't spend enough time talking
about how to produ things constructively
I agree yeah so let's do that let's do
that we'll be back with our guest in a
minute but first we want to tell you
about Factor we've discovered a
fantastic way to stay on track with you
nutritional goals while saving time if
you're in America and you're looking for
dietitian approved Chef prepared fresh
never frozen meals to fuel you on
jam-packed days then you need to take a
look at factor factor is America's
number one ready to eat meal delivery
service and they'll help you eat well
for breakfast lunch and dinner with
nutritious and flavorful ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
leave the calorie counting to their
dietitians and leave the planning
prepping and clean up to their chefs
while you're out there crushing it
factor of making sure each meal has the
nutrition you need and the flavor you're
looking for choose from over 35 Chef
crafted meals every week that support a
healthy lifestyle and meet your meal
preferences whether it's vegan veggie
Protein Plus or wholesome options there
are also calorie conscious options that
don't skimp on Flavor try delicious
dietitian approved calorie smart meals
that are under 550 calories per serving
the food is fresh and the ingredient
quality is on point for example the meat
is from grass-fed or pasture raised
animals and is free of antibiotics
hormones and GMOs it's high quality
stuff and you just have to run a Google
search to see how well Factor comes out
in reviews to try Factor head to factor
meals.com trigger 50 and use code
trigger 50 to get 50% off that's code
trigger 50 at factor meals.com to get
50% off now back to the
interview in my book I really dive into
some of this through the stories
themselves um of the different people
who have experience cancellations not
everyone in the book has but um but you
know there's a few things that people
can do what's the book called It's
called No Apologies ah very good and uh
you know it's it's about this sort of
phenomenon where people are silenced
essentially I didn't even want to call
it cancel culture because I think a lot
of it is actually just even
self-silencing
and when we self- silence we don't know
what is actually going on in the world
when anybody's thinking sometimes we're
thinking the same things and we think
we're not on the same team so one way I
know for me the way that I first started
using my voice is it's just in small
ways you know I started having open
conversations with people in
person and because it's in person it's a
different experience that gave I notice
other people permissions to discuss
these same kinds of things um and
sometimes even more sometimes
controversial things My Views are by the
way not the most controversial I would
say but um but there's a lot of topics
that are hot button topics even today
and so I noticed that once I started
doing it it had sort of an effect on
other people I mean the whole reason I
wrote this book was because I wanted to
encourage the people that I call you
know the silence ma
majority uh I wanted to empower them to
use their own voice because the only way
to kind of deal with these things is to
push back in some way and and I don't
like the idea of pushing back in you
know aggressive ways vilifying people
just mocking everybody you can mock
ideas I don't think I don't believe in
mocking people uh there's some religions
that would disagree with you on that one
cther oh yes I'm sure they will but but
you know I'll take them on I'll be
disagreeable on that one uh but I think
you you you should humor is the best way
to mock bad ideas um if you the best
most effective thing is if you can make
somebody laugh at their own bad idea
that's a superpower and that would be a
fantastic tool in your toolkit I think
um supporting people
when they're being attacked is a or
standing out for something that's a
really important thing to do as well and
people don't do it enough even if it is
just sending them a message of support
because often they think they're alone
so they don't even know people are on
their side so even if you're not willing
to you know go out publicly send them a
message of support so I think supporting
rallying out behind people um behind
people is big I think that building
communities alternative communities is
really important thing and that's
something that comes up in the book um
there's a lot of people who after having
had these experiences sort of grew their
own communities of people who have good
faith individuals people who don't just
judge people for no reason um and so
they were able to build these
alternative communities and even within
businesses you know they're able to sort
of uh appeal to an audience that's more
willing to engage with them as opposed
to appealing to everyone um I think
those are kind of small you know basic
things but at the same time important
things to do uh in order to sort of
solve I mean the other issues that are
going to be much more difficult to
overcome our
institutions and and when it comes to
institutional sort of uh issues I think
it's important to um again voice things
whether it's writing letters to
politicians because I know that
politicians when they get a letter it
counts as if it's a hundred people
because they know people don't send
letters um letting people know that
they're not alone when when things go
you know happen the really the solution
is is to speak not only I would also add
to that I think it's really important
that if you see somebody who's writing
about these issues in a way that you
don't feel able or empowered to do or
host a video channel like ours or
whatever it might be people who are
resisting this uh way of doing business
I I think if you can't speak up yourself
send that person some money or give them
a monthly subscription or whatever like
if you can't if you are so afraid
because you you're going to lose your
job for speaking and you can't speak
well support people who do speak you
know I know it's a self- serving point
from my position but I actually I've
send all your money
to absolutely we'll put the link in the
description but you I you know when I
when I was in comedy and I wasn't yet
ready to actually say what I think and
host a show like this or anything I used
to do this and I didn't have a lot of
money I used to support YouTube channels
that talked about it and and send money
to people because I thought it was like
well I can't speak but I this person is
let's give them support and encourage
them to do it because from our
perspective I can just tell you like the
more people support us the more we know
we're doing the right thing right and
the more empowered we are and also the
more resources we we have the more
radical you
have well you know it's interesting
actually because with our followers I
would we have monthly calls with like
our top
supporters the other than one exception
they're really not very radical people
at all actually they're very grateful
that moderate people are doing this uh
there are of course other people who
have a more radical position who are
more extreme I'm sure they get plenty of
support as well but it's sort of I I
feel what you're putting out there is is
what comes back so if you're radical
you're going to attract radical people
if you're moderate like the three of us
you're going to attract moderate people
who nonetheless feel that these
conversations are important I sometimes
we'll get a few radical followers which
comes out quite quickly and but they'll
leave very quickly when they realize you
radical but sometimes they they
self-reflect so it's kind of an
interesting process it's hard to do it
one on one in this way but sometimes
they do self-reflect and sort of um
change a bit because they're now
entering a more moderate Arena where
people's you know if you read people's
comments they're quite thoughtful and
nuanced and so it does sort of force
them sometimes to to go into that as
well um you're not going to catch a lot
of that a lot of change but sometimes it
does I mean I don't know if you've had
um Daryl Davis on your show the guy who
converts KKK into yeah no we haven't yet
I'm sure we will at some point he's he's
just to me and he's in the book but he
to me is such a um he's since I've heard
his background he he's been sort of I
don't want to use the word Idol I don't
worship anyone but um but it's
definitely somebody who I hold in high
regard in ter and inspired by his work
because it aligns with my own philosophy
it was like look some people are G to
and he says this in the book he's like
some people are going to go to the Grave
you know believing the racist things
that they do but some people won't some
people will change and I remember
watching um um a News segment and there
was a former member of the KKK on there
and you know you think like that's as
vile as it gets or one of and he
actually was now getting people out so
somebody had made that transformation
from being an active member of the KKK
doing illegal things um to being someone
who now battles them
people change not all people but
sometimes they do and and you can't have
that if you don't have some sort of
conversation to begin with give them
some entry point and understand why
they're the way they are absolutely and
it's not just that as well it's also
Redemption because that's the thing that
this stuff lacks this whole movement
whatever you want to call it lacks is a
possibility for people to redeem
themselves well you know what's
interesting actually I kind of tackle
this in the book because I uh there is a
chapter about false accusations true
accusations but you know this whole idea
that everything is arbitrated in the
court of public opinion
versus actual court and how do we
balance these things so um the person
that I feature in the book is Stephen
Elliot and he is somebody who was
accused he was put on this list of uh am
I allowed to say shitty shitty media men
yes shitty media men and uh you know
there was an anonymous accusation of
rape and in his case for various reasons
it's not even you know it's quite
obvious that this was not true but
regardless right it's an anonymous
accusation that's a really big factor I
remember when that list came out I
myself sort of grappled with this a
little bit because I sort of understand
the idea of wanting to warn Other Women
of you know somebody who might be a
predator I get it well in fact sorry to
just interject this in almost every
industry not that I'm a woman but I know
in almost every industry there are like
WhatsApp groups or other things where
like in comedy there are women's
WhatsApp comedy groups where that are
dedicated to the specific task of
warning fellow female comedians about
creepy people in the comedy industry so
like PE women helping other women in
this way without necessarily publicly
damaging the reputation of people who
may or may not have committed various
degrees of inappropriate you know
whatever uh they've always existed I
imagine uh through word of mouth and
things like that there's a difference
though when you're doing this in public
and people are paying the price for
anonymous allegations and so on yeah and
that's the thing I mean people are going
to whisper to each other and say hey so
and so watch out M but yeah this was a
very public list uh very publicized list
as well and you know I'm sure some of
the people on that list were guilty some
were innocent but that sort of poses the
question do we you know go after the
guilty and pay and the innocent pay the
price and so that was a question I had
to ask myself and and actually in having
the conversation with Stephen I think
that really um helped shape my own
perspective on it because I was I think
I did a little bit of a change um in my
perspective from how I originally
perceived the list and seeing what
happened to him but but there were so
many I mean kind of going into the whole
me too thing where I think it started
with some good intentions I think it did
some good things you know in terms of
bringing that conversation to the
Forefront but at the same time then you
have a lot of people who are either
innocent or the crime again just in any
of these cancel culture things like the
crime is not so big but the punishment
is the same to everyone no matter what
they've done you know somebody saying
something slightly inappropriate is not
the same as somebody raping a woman or
assaulting women or men um there's
definitely been some men who've also had
Predators Unleashed on them but it's
it's something that you know you you
have the same punishment and also it's
being decided in the court of public
public opinion a not law and that is a
very dangerous thing I agreed and the
the problem is with these movements as
they start off and you know let's talk
about me too Harvey Weinstein great
everybody agrees with it well probably
apart from Harvey but and then and then
we Harvey's probably like you one fair
enough he'll come around yeah but then
it goes on and on and on and it goes
after some people you go okay I can see
it but in order for the movement to keep
going it needs to find new injustices
and eventually you run out of injustices
so what happens is you get ANZ and Zari
who you go well he's behaved a bit of a
dick if you take what the woman says
verbatim but you can't destroy someone
for being a bit of a dick no you can
people are entitled to be dicks if they
want to be you don't have to hang out
with them or invite them to your party
but or go to their house
go to their correct but also what you
touched on is that uh they are always
seeking you injustices and we're seeing
this in a lot of uh um you know
organizations in particular for example
uh organizations that had to fight for
equal rights for gay people or marriage
okay now they don't really have anything
because they've you know maybe not fully
solved it but some pretty much solved it
uh in North America but instead of sort
of moving on to maybe countries around
the world who that have similar issues
uh that we had um they are finding other
ways because they have all this money
and they have an infrastructure and jobs
and and the monster has to sort of keep
feeding itself and I think a lot of
these um cultural issues arise from that
as well because you have all these
organizations with nothing to do so they
find you things every great cause begins
as a movement becomes a business and
eventually degenerates into a racket
Eric offer Katherine we're going to go
to locals in a second uh for all the
people who do support us uh where we ask
their questions to you before we do
though as you know we always end with
the same question which is what's the
one thing that we're not talking about
that we really should be that is a great
question I know and I know you always
ask it and how long does it take for
your guests to to uh solve that one uh
they usually all answer straight away
yeah so no press oh God darn gosh dar
okay I think that it is I think people
aren't talking I think there's a
tendency to go into ideology this
ideology is bad this ideology is good
and the way that I wish people would
talk about it more is about how it's
about Behavior it's about human behavior
and and we need to stop looking at
things from you know these polarized
sides and if if there's good ideas it's
a good idea it because it helps people
it it doesn't hurt too many people you
know and and then we can't use the
tactics that we criticize thinking that
oh we're going to win the war and then
we'll make everything right and then
we'll adhere to principles and um and
the other thing that I think people
aren't talking enough about is AI and uh
and how it's going to completely reshape
our sense of the world because of all
the disinformation that's going to
spread so we're not uh our sense of
reality is already fragmented and now
it's going to get even more because we
won't know what to believe and what not
happy news yeah all right Katherine
brosy thank you so much for coming head
on over to locals where we continue the
conversation with your
questions why is the silent majority
always associated with right-wing views
and degraded as being somehow
non-educated and
populist
[Music]